bonjour à tous alors c'est quelque chose
qui n'a pas pu vous échapper dans
quelques jours s'ouvre à paris la coop
21 la grande conférence internationale
sur le changement climatique et je me
suis dit que c'était l'occasion
d'essayer de répondre à une question
qu'on m'a souvent posé c'est assez
fréquent que de la famille ou des amis
me demandent six mois le scientifique
je crois au réchauffement climatique
alors vous savez peut-être que je suis
pas climatologue à la battue plutôt
physicien mais aujourd'hui on va
justement essayer de voir comment on
peut se faire une idée sur cette
question en utilisant le regard du
physicien
pour commencer on va rappeler qu'elle
est le raisonnement de base qui est
généralement tenu autour de la question
du changement climatique
ces raisonnements qui tient en trois
points premièrement les activités
humaines rejettent du co2 deuxièmement
le co2 est un gaz à effet de serre et
troisièmement l'effet de serre ça
réchauffe la planète
je voudrais qu'on examine un petit peu
en détail chacun de ces trois points je
vous savez peut-être que quand on brûle
un combustible qui contient du carbone
comme du bois du pétrole ou bien ici du
propane ont produit du dioxyde de
carbone le co2 qui est rejeté dans
l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère de la terre elle est
composée d'environ 78 % en azote 21%
d'oxygène et environ 1% d'argon alors le
co2 là dedans en fait il y en a beaucoup
moins que ça et donc on ne mesure pas en
pourcentage mais on le mesure en ppm ppm
ça veut dire parties par million c'est
comme un pourcentage sauf qu'au lieu
d'être 1%
c'est un pour 1 million est donc
actuellement le taux de co2 dans
l'atmosphère il est autour de 400 ppm
c'est à dire 0,04 pour cent ça c'est la
valeur aujourd'hui mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder comment
cette valeur a évolué au cours des
décennies et des siècles passés
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
parce que depuis une cinquantaine
d'années on sait mesurer directement le
co2 dans l'atmosphère et on est capable
de remonter beaucoup plus loin dans le
temps grâce à l'analyse des bulles qui
sont contenus dans des carottes de glace
alors regardons un peu ensemble
l'évolution la concentration de co2 dans
l'atmosphère on va remonter jusqu'en
l'an mil vous voyez qu à cette époque et
puis pendant plusieurs siècles ensuite
la concentration de co2 dans
l'atmosphère elle est restée autour de
280 ppm avec quelques fluctuations à la
hausse et à la baisse
et puis à partir des années 1850 il
s'est passé un truc il ya eu la
révolution industrielle et le taux de
co2 dans l'atmosphère a commencé à
grimper grimper grimper à et à tel point
qu'il faut que je change l'échelle de
mon graphique en fait faut que cela
change plusieurs fois
et voilà le record actuel en 2015
il est juste au dessus de 400 ppm je
crois qu'il ya pas besoin d'épiloguer
très longtemps sur cette courbe je pense
que vous voyez la tendance 1 il faut
être tout à fait clair sur un point
cette courbe on a absolument aucun doute
dessus personne ne la conteste un même
le plus climato-sceptiques des climato
sceptiques il est obligé de reconnaître
que c'est vraiment ça qui est en train
de se passer avec le taux de co2 dans
l'atmosphère aujourd'hui ça c'est pour
le premier point
avant de traiter le second degré qu'on
commence par regarder le troisième
l'idée selon laquelle l'effet de serre
réchauffent la planète
il faut savoir que la terre elle tire
quasiment toute son énergie du
rayonnement solaire comme la surface du
soleil est là environ 5500 degrés la
lumière qui nous envoie c'est
principalement de la lumière visible de
l'ultraviolet et ce qu'on appelle de
l'infrarouge proche la terre elle va
réfléchir directement une partie de ce
rayonnement à environ 30 % et elle va
absorber le reste est donc c'est ça qui
lui fournit son énergie comme tout cork
et chauffée à une certaine température
la terre elle va elle aussi maîtres du
rayonnement mais comme elle est loin
d'être aussi chaude que le soleil ce
rayonnement là ça va pas être du visible
ultraviolets ça va être qu'on appelle de
l'infrarouge lointain
vous savez c'est ce qu'on peut voir
quand on met des lunettes de vision
nocturne
alors il faut savoir que s'il n'y avait
pas du tout d'effet de serre tous
rayonnement infrarouge lointain émis par
la terre y repartirait dans l'espace et
il ferait environ moins 18 degrés à la
surface de la terre en moyenne il n'y a
pas besoin de faire de grandes
climatologie pour trouver ce chiffre là
c'est vraiment juste deux lignes de
calcul si on connaît la physique du
rayonnement thermique
sauf qu'on voit bien que c'est pas ça
qui se passe sur terre en réalité effet
pas moins 18 degrés en moyenne
la raison c'est que ce rayonnement
infrarouge lointain qui est émis par la
terre
il est fortement absorbée par les gaz de
l'atmosphère et il est réunie en partie
vers la terre ça crée un flux
supplémentaire qui contribuent à
réchauffer la planète et donc c'est ça
qu'on appelle l'effet de serre et c'est
grâce à cet effet de serre qui fait pas
moins 18 degrés en moyenne sur la
planète mais il fait plutôt 14 degrés et
ça on peut le trouver en cinq civils de
calcul
donc vous voyez que l'effet de serre
c'est un phénomène absolument
incontestable il n'y a absolument aucun
débat sur sa réalité il n'ya pas besoin
de grands modèles climatologiques pour
montrer qu'il a des effets de serre
c'est juste de la physique et d'ailleurs
heureusement même qui a l'effet de serre
puisqu'on vient le voir c'est ce qui
permet que la planète soit une
température moyenne d'environ 14 degrés
plutôt que moins 18
et donc ça évite de vivre dans un grand
désert glacé d'ailleurs il ya une autre
illustration bien connu l'effet de serre
c'est le fait en apparence un peu
paradoxal que la surface de vénus soit
plus chaudes en moyenne que celles de
mercure alors que mercure est plus
proche du soleil
et bien c'est parce que l'atmosphère de
vénus elle est composée à 96 % de co2
qui crée un effet de serre énorme
tout ça nous amène au second point que
j'ai pas encore examiné le fait que le
co2 soit un gaz à effet de serre c'est
vrai ça pourquoi le co2 est pas
l'oxygène par exemple qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un gaz données est un gaz à effet de
serre et là on l'a vu tout à l'heure
pour qu'ils aient effet de serre il faut
que le rayonnement infrarouge lointain
puisse être absorbés par l'atmosphère
alors sans rentrer dans les détails pour
qu'un gaz puisse absorber les
infrarouges
il faut qu'ils soient composés de au
moins trois atomes dans sa molécule ou
alors éventuellement seulement deux
atomes à condition que ce soit deux
atomes différents mondes oncle co2 baïla
trois atomes donc c'est un gaz à effet
de serre l'oxygène est là zot
et ben non ils sont tous les deux
composés de deux atomes identique
le méthane ch4 bah oui l'argon un seul
atome donc non l'ozone o3 trois atomes
donc que oui et oui
l'ozone dont la couche nous protège des
uv c'est aussi un gaz à effet de serre
et d'ailleurs tous les gaz cfc ceux qui
justement détruisent la couche d'ozone
sont aussi des gaz à effet de serre et
puis et puis la vapeur d'eau h2o
bah oui trois atomes la vapeur d'eau
donc la vapeur d'eau c'est un gaz à
effet de serre et c'est même un des plus
puissants
alors là vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi on nous en demande avec le co2
et qu'on nous parle jamais de la vapeur
d'eau c'est vrai quoi si je me fais
bouillir de l'eau pour faire un thé est
ce que je contribue à augmenter l'effet
de serre et à réchauffer la planète
et ben non en fait est une raison pour
ça et c'est vraiment important la
comprendre on ne peut pas durablement
modifier la quantité de vapeur d'eau
contenue dans l'atmosphère est la raison
pour ça c'est que la vapeur d'eau de
l'atmosphère elle est
en équilibre avec les océans si on
essaye d'augmenter artificiellement la
concentration en vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère par exemple je sais pas on
se met tous à se faire d'été à prendre
des grandes douches chaudes tous
ensemble et ben en quelques jours
l'océan aura absorbé tout le surplus et
la concentration de vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère sera revenu à sa valeur
normale donc oui c'est vrai la vapeur
d'eau est un des plus important gaz à
effet de serre mais on ne peut pas
durablement modifié sa concentration
dans l'atmosphère
contrairement au co2 qui on l'a vu lui
s'accumulent dangereusement
donc si on revient sur nos trois points
voyez qu'il ya absolument aucun doute et
aucun débat sur le mécanisme du
réchauffement climatique
ça vient pas de la climatologie c'est
vraiment juste de la physique et c'est
même pas de la physique super compliqué
bon donc là j'espère vous avoir
convaincus que le raisonnement il est
absolument incontestable sauf sauf que
sur des questions aussi sérieuses que ça
on veut pas se contenter d'un
raisonnement qualitatif
ok le mécanisme est là ça c'est clair
mais en chiffres ça fait combien
on a vu tout à l'heure que le taux de
co2 dans l'atmosphère il était d'environ
280 ppm avant la révolution industrielle
depuis il a augmenté de quasiment 50% ce
co2 supplémentaires qui a été balancé
dans l'atmosphère depuis la révolution
industrielle y provoque un effet de
serre plus gros que ce qui devrait être
naturellement et pour quantifier ça on
va essayer de mettre sa sous la forme
d'un surplus de rayonnement qu'il est dû
à cet effet de serre additionnel alors
avant de parler du surplus de
rayonnement on va déjà voir ce que le
soleil nous envoient déjà à la base
si vous mettez juste au dessus de
l'atmosphère et que vous tourner vers le
soleil vient de face vous allez recevoir
un flux d'environ 1366 watts par mètre
carré
donc ça c'est la valeur maximum sauf
qu'il ya deux choses à prendre en compte
la première c'est que un endroit donné
de la terre mais il va pas être en
permanence juste face au soleil à son
orientation va changer et en plus en
moyenne bail sera la moitié du temps
dans la nuit
donc la puissance moyenne qui va
effectivement être reçus sur chaque
mètre carré de la terre c'est seulement
un quart de la valeur maximale
la deuxième chose qu'il faut considérer
c'est qu'on l'a dit la terre va
réfléchir directement environ 30% de ce
rayonnement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la halle benno au
total si on fait le calcul on trouve que
la terre reçoit un flux solaire moyen
d'environ 240 watts par mètre carré
l'effet du co2 qui a été accumulé dans
l'atmosphère par rapport au niveau qu'il
y avait avant la révolution industrielle
il équivaut un surplus de rayonnement
d'environ 2 watts par mètre carré
et puis si on ajoute les autres gaz à
effet de serre le total c'est à peu près
3 watts par mètre carré ce surplus de
rayonnement on appelle ça le forçage
radiatif un forçage radiatif de 3 watts
par mètre carré ça veut dire que c'est
comme si le soleil
au lieu de nous balancer 240 watts par
mètre carré il nous en balançait 243 en
gros c'est comme si le soleil brillait
rhin pour cent plus fort alors ça paraît
pas grand chose mais c'est quand même ça
qui menace de tout changer j'en profite
pour faire une petite parenthèse il ya
un argument climato-sceptiques classique
qui dit que le réchauffement qu'on
observe actuellement il serait pas due
au gaz à effet de serre émis par l'homme
mais ils seraient dus aux variations
naturelles de la puissance du soleil
alors c'est vrai la puissance que le
soleil émet elle varie naturellement
selon des cycles et on peut même la
mesure et vous voyez la courbe ici est
en fait derrière le chiffre moyen
d'environ 1366 watts par mètre carré que
je
donnez tout à l'heure se cache en fait
des variations de plus ou moins 0,5
mètre par mètre carré selon un cycle qui
dure onze ans ça c'est pour la puissance
maximale une fois qu'on a pris en compte
la division par 4 et puis l'albédo de
30%
il reste moins de 0,1 watt par mètre
carré de variations au niveau du sol
donc le forçage radiatif duo cycle
solaire c01 watts par mètre carré et on
a vu que le forçage radiatif due au gaz
à effet de serre émis par l'homme depuis
la révolution industrielle
c'est 3 watts par mètre carré bon bah
voilà n'y a pas de comparaison
bien donc on a vu que l'effet des gaz à
effet de serre qui ont été émis par
l'homme depuis la révolution
industrielle
ça équivaut un forçage radiatif
d'environ 3 watts par mètre carré
maintenant la question c'est quel impact
ça va avoir sur la température moyenne à
la surface de la terre
donc si on ajoute ces 3 watts par mètre
carré dans notre modèle tout simple qui
tient en quelques lignes on trouve que
cet effet de serre supplémentaires
provoque une hausse d'environ un degré
de la température à la surface de la
terre gronde dit comme ça ça paraît pas
grand chose un degré 1
oui sauf que ça c'est pour les valeurs
actuelles de concentration des gaz à
effet de serre si on continue à en
rejeter comme si de rien était
évidemment ça va augmenter
et puis il ya un autre facteur à prendre
en compte c'est à vapeur d'eau alors oui
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure à la
vapeur d'eau c'est le plus important des
gaz à effet de serre sauf qu'on peut pas
modifier sa concentration dans
l'atmosphère
sauf que il ya un truc qui permet de
modifier sa concentration
c'est si on augmente la température
puisque je vous ai dit le fait que la
concentration de vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère soit stabilisée c'est lié à
son interaction avec l'océan sauf que
vous savez peut-être que l'air chaud
peut contenir plus d'humidité que l'air
froid et donc si la planète se réchauffe
il va pouvoir les voir plus de vapeur
d'eau dans l'atmosphère et donc si la
température augmente à cause de l'effet
de serre dû au co2 l'atmosphère va
pouvoir stocker plus de vapeur d'eau qui
va provoquer plus d'effet de serre qui
va encore accroître le réchauffement
ce qu'on a là c'est ce qu'on appelle une
rétroaction positive
alors on dit rétroaction positive parce
que le phénomène se renforce lui même il
s'auto aggrave évidemment pour nous
c'est pas positif du tout hein alors des
rétroactions positives de gens là il y
en a d'autres
par exemple si la banquise se met à
fondre et bien la terre va réfléchir -
de rayonnement solaire
donc va en absorber plus ce qui va
contribuer encore à aggraver son cas
alors ces rétroactions positives on
pourrait imaginer qu'elle conduise à un
phénomène d'emballement ou de
réchauffement s'entretient lui-même et
la terre se réchauffe de plus en plus on
pense que c'est ce qui s'est d'ailleurs
passé sur vénus heureusement les
spécialistes estiment que c'est peu
probable que ça se produise pour nous
une des choses qui nous fait dire ça
c'est que il ya des centaines de
millions d'années
l'atmosphère de la terre contenait cinq
à dix fois plus de co2 que ce qu'elle a
aujourd'hui
et les températures étaient
vraisemblablement supérieur d'au moins 5
degrés et pourtant la planète s'en est
remise ça veut dire qu'en plus des
rétroactions positives
il existe aussi des rétroaction négative
c'est-à-dire des mécanismes qui viennent
freiner et contrebalancer le phénomène
d'effet de serre il ya par exemple les
nuages
on sait que si la concentration en
vapeur d'eau augmente la quantité de
nuages peu augmenté et qu'ils
contribuent à renvoyer une partie du
rayonnement solaire et donc à modérer
leur échauffement
sauf qu estimer la contribution exacte
de ces rétroaction négative c'est assez
difficile et la meilleure manière qu'on
est de le faire c'est de faire des
modèles très détaillé qui prennent en
compte
l'atmosphère les océans les courants etc
et de simuler tout ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un modèle de circulation
générale
alors oui c'est vrai quand on utilise
ces modèles il ya des incertitudes
c'est lié notamment au fait que tous les
modèles ne prennent pas en compte de la
même manière les effets de ces
rétroactions positives et négatives et
du coup quand on simule une situation
donnée avec tous les modèles
et bien il ne donne pas les mêmes
augmentations de température ce que vous
voyez ici par exemple c'est un scénario
donner des missions et chaque ligne
bleue représente la prédiction d'un
modèle est à 42 modèles et donc ils font
tout une prédiction différentes et il ya
une incertitude sur l'élévation de
température à la fin ça ça vient des
rapports du giec donc contrairement à ce
qu'on entend parfois les résultats du
giec sont totalement transparents sur le
fait qu' il existe des incertitudes de
modélisation mais franchement vous
trouvez que ça change le message en gros
on a un phénomène qui je le répète sur
le plan physique est absolument
incontestable les humains émettent du
co2 le co2 est un gaz à effet de serre
l'effet de serre réchauffent la planète
les seules choses qui restent en suspens
c'est de savoir si avec un peu de chance
les rétroaction négative vont pas être
un petit peu plus bénéfique puisque on
s'imaginer avoir à prendre une analogie
voulait sauter par la fenêtre du sixième
étage la physique de base est assez
claire sur ce qui va se passer
vous allez tomber et puis au niveau du
sol bas vous avez vous écraser sauf que
mouais sauf qu'il ya quelques
incertitudes parce que ça se trouve
si vous sautez du 6e au cinquième il ya
un balcon un petit peu plus long qui va
vous rattraper ou bien une fois arrivé
au niveau du sol en fait il ya un gros
tas de poubelles et vous allez atterrir
sur le tas de poubelles qui va freiner
votre chute et vous allez vous en tirez
donc oui il broie ya quelques
incertitudes
mais c'est quand même pas sûr du coup
vous faites quoi vous sauter quand même
j'espère que mon message il éclaire un
oui c'est vrai il ya des incertitudes
sur l'augmentation de température exacte
qu'on va avoir du fait de tous les gaz à
effet de serre qu'on rejette dans
l'atmosphère
ce que vous voyez là par exemple c'est
les simulations du giec pour le scénario
ou essentiellement on se tourne les
pouces et on fait rien et vous voyez la
cour moyenne et vous voyez les
incertitudes liées aux modèles et donc
il subsiste un doute pour savoir si en
2100 on sera effectivement à trois
degrés de plus parce que les rétroaction
négative
or ont été plutôt favorables ou bien au
contraire on sera à 5 degrés de plus
alors on sera probablement quelque part
entre les deux mais c'est pas parce
qu'il subsiste des incertitudes qu'il
faut rien faire c'était le sens de mon
analogie dussault par la fenêtre
vous savez on parle souvent de sauver la
planète en fait c'est pas vrai la
planète elle s'en fout la planète elle
va s'en remettre un je vous ai dit il ya
déjà eu des périodes de l'histoire la
terre où il y avait cinq fois plus de
co2 et il faisait 5 degrés de plus et la
terre elle s'en est très bien tiré
d'ailleurs c'était même d époque assez
sympa par exemple citer le cas au
jurassique vous savez à l'époque où il y
avait notamment les dinosaures non la
terre elle va s'en remettre un nancy le
changement climatique dont on parle
aujourd'hui se produit réellement il ya
une espèce qui va morfler surtout c'est
non voilà bon enfin j'ai pas nous faire
la leçon et je pense que vous la
connaissez
il faut qu'on fasse tous des efforts
pour essayer de consommer moins
d'énergie et en particulier moins
d'énergies fossiles
mais quand même c'est pas sûr que ça
suffise
je pense que la science et la
technologie vont aussi avoir leur rôle à
jouer là-dedans et en tant que
vulgarisateur scientifique c'est un peu
là dessus j'avais envie de finir je
crois qu'il faut aussi que les sociétés
dans lesquelles on vit fasse des efforts
collectifs pour essayer d'encourager la
recherche scientifique qui permettra
peut-être de produire des technologies
pour consommer moins d'énergie ou alors
produire de l'énergie plus propre donc
je sais pas moi des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui serait plus efficace
et moins cher ou bien quelque chose
autour de l'hydrogène ou de la fusion
nucléaire moi j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que ça va
pas à s'inventer tout ça bref prenez le
vélo prenez les transports en commun
mais n'oubliez pas aussi je sais pas moi
d'écrire à votre député pour lui dire de
soutenir la recherche en sciences et en
technologie parce que c'est aussi une
des clés du problème
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo comme
d'habitude n'hésitez pas à la partager
surtout si vous avez des amis qui ne
pas vraiment au réchauffement climatique
comme d'habitude vous pouvez me
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook et twitter c'est le meilleur
son propre aura des infos sur la chaîne
ce qu'ils souhaitent peuvent soutenir
sur tipi merci infiniment à tous les
types heures qui vous soutiennent et
puis vous pouvez aussi vous retrouvez
sur le blog qui s'appelle science
étonnante merci à bientôt